[Applause]
[Music]
foree
me
my
[Music]
[Applause]
you are so good give it up for Mato y
thank you thank you welcome to the cell
ckson show give it up for my band y'all
along with our very special guest
9-year-old Mel Lopez known as the
youngest Mariachi in the
world
so Mato he is back with us that
rendition of Frank sinra my way or Ami
Mana am Mara Mana okay I tried um it's
in Spanish in honor of world Mariachi
day which is this Sunday so do you have
plans for World Mariachi day yes I have
a lot of plans one I am going to invite
I'm going to invite all my miai friends
to have a big jam session and just sing
it's it doesn't even matter if we mess
up we just keep going exactly have a
good time with it yeah do you have any
performances that we know about coming
up yep so I have the San Antonio Rodeo
all the way back in my hometown San
Antonio yeah then I have the 32nd annual
Mariachi Spectacular in Albuquerque oh
that's amazing man good luck good luck
you are welcome to sing here anytime
beautiful Mato is actually going to be
hanging out the entire show and we're
setting him up with the best seat in the
house inside our VIP Ware Lounge um and
actually my kids River and Remy are here
today and they're going to be hanging
out with you so you can head on up if
you want to go up all right thank you
byebye thank you all
[Music]
[Applause]
right thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going home h